moonshine that has installed metal bars
on all balconies after two third grade
pupils committed suicide in six months
puncturing number two middle school
boasts nearly 10,000 top performing
students is known for its highly
stressful military-style management not
only your students forced to get up at
5:30 a.m. and study for at least 10
hours a day but all meals have a
15-minute time limit and students are
only given one holiday every 30 years
pictures of the school's new balcony
fence first appeared last week on
China's equivalent of Twitter caption in
order to prevent pupils from jumping off
the building punctual middle school has
spent a fortune another user commented
this is indeed a school but in order to
stop people from taking their lives
it has made itself look like a prison so
I want to do the story because I came
across one of those pictures on Twitter
with the bars and it just blew my mind
that really what they're doing in these
schools is turning this into jail and
then what I'm saying it looks like the
project's I grew up next to it the
wrongs yeah so 10 hours this is some of
those numbers you what your hours of
studying a 15 minute break I mean the
experience of growing up is supposed to
be like right I think when I read that
and made me not feel so bad about
medicating my child you medicate your
child they're quiet they're walking
around like zombies zombies can't jump a
little meat on the other side a zombie
Joe does this just seem crazy like I
know I know what a lot of the commenters
are gonna say is that well look where
China is in the world in education
they're gonna say that's why they've
surpassed America and so many things in
there what's the pressure the bars or or
or their intense mode of Education so
let's start with the mode of Education
first like is that just too much
empirically is that kind of studying for
third graders where they could consider
suicide is that just too well and again
we don't know ever I don't know I'll let
an expert in change
did you see they had a video and I also
read online that they have the children
they line up and they throw their hands
in the air we won't succeed and anytime
I see children throwing their hand in
the air and yelling we will
succeed and reminds me of Nazis it is a
little happy I recite the Pledge of
Allegiance every morning makes me think
Nazis - I'll see who I can piss off in
my next segment
yeah all right so the bars I mean it
just doesn't that in and of itself for
getting the amount that they're working
but just to have kids in a learning
environment where they're trapped like
that doesn't that just seem crazy that's
crazy as far as safety wise if there's a
fire there is you know that is kind of
crazy they're attractive bars though you
have to admit the welding in it the
parks a lot what do you know look you
know we're all adults here and we can't
open a window in a hotel so I used to
judge what do you think is worse like
the growing up in our education system
where so many kids are slipped through
the cracks and then their whole lives
are ruined because they don't get the
education they deserve or going through
something that could break you but
you're gonna learn and then when I see
stuff like that I feel bad for China
itself because they're so regimented and
so like strict that they're that the
creative ones that are there that are
gonna actually bring something creative
and something out out of the box to
their society I think that just kills
that yeah so is that the part they're
missing so for for three creative types
in comedy is that the part how do you
then I need you to create they seem to
be doing they're doing great there no I
mean what are you gonna say what are you
gonna compare you're gonna say it's
worse than the education system state
education system here in America by the
way can I just say this to your viewers
yeah about the education system I just
saw a fantastic documentary called
Waiting for Superman which is really
really terrific if you're interested in
how and why our education system is is
in such trouble this documentary gets
into the the problems of what how hard
it is to fix our education system so I
just want to pass that on what is the
one thing you
that movie about the education system
that's specifically um it's it's become
a bureaucratic nightmare and so to
affect change is virtually impossible
because you're dealing with people's
livelihoods and you're dealing with with
Union rules and you're dealing with all
sorts of structures that make it
impossible to do any fundamental changes
and until the institution of this
bureaucracy can change it's very
difficult to effect change from within
it but but I just wanted to pass that on
I'm not speaking for it I just think
it's a fascinating no well I think
that's actually a good takeaway there so
okay we've got our system right here
totally warped and our education systems
is one of the worst in the Western world
we've got China where it seems to be
working right their economy is going
great and yet they have bars on their
windows so if you're in a country that's
somewhere between them you're saying
what you're saying that like it's not
true here I mean what bars on on half
the schools in New York right but what
were they but where the bars not to stop
the kids from killing themselves it was
to stop violence
I guess Outsiders coming in or I don't
know what's the difference
the system is seriously [ __ ] what do
you think let us know in the comments